guten morgen meine damen und herren wir
schauen auf einen wahlabend zurück der
uns auch als sieger gesehen hat sie
hatten gerade die presse vom 19 gröden
lief bayern natürlich zu unserer
betrübnis noch mehr als wir aber das
soll nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass
wir bei dieser wahl zum europäischen
parlament über die werde ich sprechen
kollege markus bremen wird dann später
über die bremer bürgerschaftswahl
sprechen und ich sprechen jetzt zunächst
einmal zur wahl zum europäischen
parlament am einem wahlsieg errungen wir
waren 2014 mit 7,1 prozent gestartet und
sind jetzt heute morgen neues sozial mit
11,0 prozent raus wir haben 50 prozent
zugewinne gegenüber der letzten wahl zum
europäischen parlament
es wurde gestern ganz gerne mal der
vergleich versucht zur bundestagswahl wo
wir bekanntermaßen mit 12,6 prozent
abgeschnitten haben und dann wurde der
der versuch gemacht ja habt ihr jetzt
nicht schlechter abgeschnitten seid ihr
nicht nicht gesunken
das ist aber wie sie unschwer erkennen
können vergleich von äpfeln mit birnen
weil wir natürlich hier bei der wahl zum
europäischen parlament keine fünf
prozent klausel haben was zur folge
hatte dass ich glaube es waren insgesamt
41 parteien angetreten sind und diese
klein und kleinstparteien die hatten
knapp 14 prozent aller stimmen auf sich
vereinigt und das muss man natürlich
abziehen bei der ganzen geschichte so
dass elf prozent in der europawahl in
etwa eine parallelentwicklung sind zu
den 12,6 prozent tiefer bei der
bundestagswahl haben wir sind also weder
gestiegen noch noch sonderlich gefallen
das ist ein sehr starker effekt sie
können das auch an den sitzen sehen die
die kleinen parteien neuerungen haben
ist eine welt für sich
wir haben des weiteren auch das für uns
ein schöner erfolg doppelt so viele
stimmen wie die fdp und die linke wenn
sie die fdp die linke zusammen fassen
dann haben die insgesamt etwas weniger
stimmen als wir alleine gemacht haben
auch das zeigt dass wir fest etabliert
im parteienspektrum da stehen gefragt
wird immer um die frage werden
sicherlich von ihnen kommen was in dem
die ursachen für eigentlich vielleicht
besseres ergebnis jede partei wünscht
sich immer noch besseres ergebnis gehabt
hat das sind gründe die ihnen
wahrscheinlich auch relativ klar sind
wir hatten massive behinderungen zum
einen durch wir nennen das klar seinen
namen durch links terroristische taten
und sind wahlkampf autos abgefackelt
worden ich habe in essen vor drei völlig
ausgebrannten gebrannten autos gestanden
unsere plakatierer sind attackiert
worden wären massive hacker zerstörung
eine plakat ihre rinn wurde so heftig
den bauch getreten dass im krankenhaus
behandelt werden musste und sind
wahllokale gekündigt worden weil die so
genannte antifa mit vergeltungsschlägen
gedroht hat das ist die realität im jahr
2019 in deutschland für den fall dass
man an uns vermietet infolgedessen
konnten wir dann zum beispiel keine
wahlkampf abschlussveranstaltung in
bremen machen weil wir schlicht keine
kleine lokale bekam dazu kam
betrachten sie es nicht als den vorwurf
oder so sie wollen doch geballte
medienkampagnen lege sich die spiele
gegen uns was für über vermeintlich
rechtsextrem oder ähnliches wird auch
sein das ging bis in den gestrigen
wahlabend hinein
da waren's formulierungen der caravan
aktiven noch im kopf schütteln und das
hat sicherlich zu teilen auch menschen
erreichen und hat dann noch besseres
ergebnis verhindert es ist müßig darüber
zu spekulieren inwieweit die sogenannte
ibiza affäre aus österreich sich
niedergeschlagen hat bei uns sich selbst
vermute aber wir alle wissen das nicht
weil wir dauernd dazu keine empirie
haben dass der effekt nicht sonderlich
stark war
wir würden aber auch nicht behaupten
dass er daran gar nicht da war das heißt
ein bisschen stimmen weggefressen haben
dürfte das schon was die anderen
parteien schon festgestellt haben und
was was heute sehr stark durch die
medien ging
sicherlich war das thema klimapolitik
und die hier verbreitete history um
dieses thema etwas was uns nicht in die
karten gespielt hat das heißt dieses
thema wurde wurde nach oben gehabt die
menschen wurden damit in sehr großer
zahl erreicht und das ist sicherlich
etwas was den grünen in die karten
gespielt hat weil viele menschen allen
das glauben die grünen hätten hier
vernünftige lösungen im angebot was
natürlich nicht der fall ist das thema
ist aber so stark ja ich sag mal schon
ersatz religiös besetzt dass man damit
mit mit fakten und mit vernünftige
analyse gar nicht mehr durchdringt das
ist die problematik dass bei exit chaos
im britischen unterhaus eine rolle
gespielt haben und wir waren vielleicht
etwas zu mutig das ist aber unsere mut
zur wahrheit dexxit und austritt aus dem
ep überhaupt oder beenden des
europäischen parlament ist als
institution ins wahlprogramm aufzunehmen
das hat innere logik ist aber vielleicht
eine geschichte die uns nicht in die
karten gespielt hat insgesamt wenn man
dass das deutsche wahlergebnis nehmen
wir haben niedergang ehemaliger
volksparteien bei aufstieg zweier neuer
zu verzeichnen das ist eine geradezu
historische entwicklung setzt sich fort
dazu wird aber in der aula neben da ich
noch weiteres sagen haben uns das ein
bisschen so aufgeteilt
ich sag jetzt noch ganz schnell ein paar
worte zum ergebnis insgesamt darf an die
gesamte redezeit von 15 minuten auf dem
podium erinnern damit er endlich frei
als zeit für fragen und wie viel habe
ich sie sind eigentlich schon drüber mal
15 minuten insgesamt also drei ich will
jetzt ganz schnell
wir haben sehr erfreuliche ergebnisse
bei den meisten weiß meine meisten
anderen europäischen partner parteien
lega 33,6 prozent
rational 23,5 in österreich ist der
einbruch nicht so groß wie wir
befürchten mussten die rund 17,2 braig
cit partie voller erfolg und sie sehen
in diesen ländern übrigens österreich
hier mal ausgenommen
dass sich diese die dieser niedergang
der ehemaligen volksparteien dort schon
viel weiter vollzogen hat als hier
hier ist das sozusagen in progress und
wird sich wird sich sicherlich weiter
fortsetzen
ich lasse jetzt aus zeitgründen mal
polen dänemark finnland und spanien
becky wo das auch sehr interessant wäre
vielleicht kommen dazu er noch fragen
wir haben insgesamt ein deutliches
erstarken des rechts konservativ
freiheitlichen lagers und je nachdem wie
die neue fraktion sich zusammensetzen
wir diese gespräche gehen jetzt los ich
bin ab morgen in brüssel und hat dann
laufen auch diese gespräche werden wir
mindestens dritter viertstärkste
fraktion im europäischen parlament sein
je nachdem wie wir uns zu sein
finden wenn sich die ganz große fraktion
ergeben sollte denn wer auf
zweitstärkste fraktion werden können das
eingelegte sei und ich vermute dass wenn
sie gleich noch ein paar fragen haben
von meiner seite dankeschön und ich
glaube dass meine damen und herren ich
will mich kurz fassen was man an den
wahlergebnissen sieht ist leider eine
spaltung deutschlands sie brauchen sich
nur die ergebnisse in den ostdeutschen
bundesländern mit denen die
westdeutschen bundesländer und im
vergleich anzuschauen
in den ostdeutschen bundesländern sind
wir weit gehen zu sagen entweder eins
oder zwei und die volksparteien haben
noch sehr viel stärker abgewirtschaftet
aber da ich mich kurz fassen muss nur
ein paar sätze noch zu unseren
konkurrenzparteien herrmann hat sich
angedeutet in die grünen sind für uns
der hauptgegner die grünen sind die
partei die deutschland ruinieren die den
verbrennungsmotor abschaffen wollen
die die kohleförderung abschaffen wollen
insofern müssen wir gegen die grünen
kämpfen das ist das hauptziel muss auch
das hauptziel in der bundestagsfraktion
sein
die cdu hat keine stärkung durch hkk
erfahren sie hat verloren verharrt auf
einem verhältnismäßig niedrigen niveau
die spd ist als volkspartei am ende
linken und fdp sind es ist es nicht
gelungen
irgend ein profil für die wähler
deutlich zu machen also zusammengefasst
nochmal die grünen sind unser
hauptgegner sie sind die partei die am
weitesten von uns entfernt ist das sage
ich ganz ausdrücklich denn die linken
haben im osten eine rolle in dem sie
sozusagen die lebensleistungen der ort
die in der ddr gelebt haben immer wieder
thematisieren
die grünen werden dieses land zerstören
wenn sie tatsächlich ans regieren kommen
und unsere aufgabe muss und wird sein
gegen die grünen zu kämpfen
danke ja danke guten morgen meine damen
und herren
eingangs zu den bremischen ergebnissen
ist zu bemerken es gibt nach wie vor
kein wirkliches ergebnis
wir bewegen uns irgendwo um die sieben
prozent herum was ich sage mal gegenüber
oder vor dem spezifischen bremischen
hintergrund ein deutlicher erfolg ist zu
meinen vorrednern ist anzumerken alles
was die schon gesagt haben
das geht in bremen ganz genauso
allerdings ist noch um eine gewaltige
nur aus verschärft in bremen findet das
ganze wie unter einem brennglas noch mal
verstärkt statt was in ganz deutschland
eben halt auch abläuft außer mit
ausnahme des deutschen ostens
wahrscheinlich es ist zu bemerken wir
haben gegenüber den ergebnissen der
letzten bürgerschaftswahl zugelegt wir
haben unser hauptziel erreicht nämlich
in fraktionsstärke einzuziehen
wir haben unser ziel etwa eine 8 vorne
stehen zu haben wohl offensichtlich
nicht erreicht das sind ich persönlich
sehr bedauerlich denn ich glaube wir
haben einen sehr engagierten einen sehr
guten wahlkampf gemacht und insofern
hätte ich mir ein besseres ergebnis
gewünscht allerdings ist das was wie
gesagt schon schon erwähnt wurde
wir haben massiven gegenwind in unserem
wahlkampf gehabt wir haben erhebliche
ersparnisse zu verkämpfen gehabt wir
haben mit van mit einschüchterungen mit
terror von links zu tun gehabt
unvorstellbaren ausmaßes das wird ein
wirklich ein bezeichnendes licht auf den
politischen diskurs in diesem land wo
mittlerweile angekommen ist gut dann
gibt es noch ein paar eintrübende
spezifika aus bremen wir haben eine
kleine regionale partei die uns ein bis
zwei prozent sicherlich im ergebnis
gekostet hat sonst wird es auch noch ein
bisschen mehr
ein bisschen besser geworden eine
anmerkung noch zur zukunft zur
bremischen zukunft der wählerauftrag ist
nun ganz klar
er geht zur regierungsbildung an die cdu
ich befürchte allerdings dass wir die
beugung des wählerwillens durch die
grünen erleben werden die bereiten das
offensichtliche moment schon vor
es wird immer wieder kolportiert die
basis würde eine jamaika koalition also
cdu/fdp/grüne nicht mittragen und
insofern müsse man also dem
wahlverlierer der spd eben halt mit
einer rot-rot-grünen koalition bei
springen und das scheint in diese
richtung zu gehen und dazu ist
anzumerken bei uns in bremen heißt es es
muss jetzt mal schlechter werden bevor
es besser werden kann allerdings zu
bringen die das insofern nicht weil in
bremen ist schon alles schlecht und es
wäre an der zeit dass es jetzt wirklich
besser wird danke so weit ich danke
allen drei herren mehr kommen zu fragen
und das gelte auch hier eine frage erst
mal und dann eine nachfrage wenn noch
zeit über bleibt können wir gerne in
eine zweite runde einsteigen und ich
bitte auch jeweils um eine kurze
vorstellung weil nicht alle antennen
bitte schön hier vorne geht es los
herr kollege roger telegraph aus holland
nochmal anhören wollten sie haben ein
bisschen gewonnen
bei dieser wahl aber ich glaube man
konnte auch sehen dass neun von zehn
deutsche wähler nicht für ihre partei
gewählt haben und meine frage ist
eigentlich ja woran könnte das gelegen
haben vielleicht diese straf- er habe
sich schon angesprochen dass man gesehen
hat ihren freund straßen aus österreich
mit dieser unfassbare einladung umzug
schon eine russische oligarchen und aus
ihren problemen gemacht hat und
vielleicht auch die spendenaffäre in
jeder eigene parteien bei ihnen
vielleicht persönlich also das
vielleicht auch mitgespielt können sie
da ein wort darüber verlieren und dann
wenn sie erlauben vorhin bei der havag
war hier und er hat seine partei oder
bisher mit kaninchen verglichen auch mit
kampf kaninchen die manchmal so wie es
vielleicht wieder aufnehmen würden
mit welchem tier
würden sie sich oder ihre partei
vergleichen eine tierische frage also
über die die ursachen warum wir nicht
noch besser abgeschnitten haben noch mal
wir haben einen erfolg wir haben 50
prozent zuwachs im ergebnis von 71 auf
11 prozent gestiegen
wenn sie jetzt sagen warum wir die
anderen 90 prozent nicht haben dann
antworte ich ihnen zunächst einmal eine
demokratie haben und weil in einer
demokratie nicht alle einer meinung sein
müssen dass so viele uns nicht gewählt
haben gilt übrigens für alle anderen
parteien auch niemand ist von einem
absoluten mehrheit gewählt worden und
haben mit deutlichem abstand nicht hat
eine vielzahl von gründen über die habe
ich jemandem eingang statement schon
gesprochen
ich persönlich glaube dass die diese
sprache affäre nicht sich nicht so stark
ausgewirkt hat auf das wahlergebnis
und ich glaube auch nicht dass die
sogenannte spendenaffäre die media
reichlich aufgebauscht ist hinter der
weit weit weniger substanz ist als
allgemein gerne behauptet wird weil das
natürlich gerne aufgegriffen wird um uns
zu schaden
ich glaube nicht dass das sich das stark
ausgewirkt hat übrigens auch nicht die
geschichte mit dem prüfer als
verfassungsschutz das sind die die
üblichen versuche uns zu diskreditieren
das ist aber in einem bereich der nicht
maßgeblich ist wenn ich es vermuten
sollte aber das bleibt euch die
spekulativ am tag nach der wahl weil
darüber keine empirischen befunde haben
glaube ich persönlich dass das durch
regen des klima thema mit dem wir nicht
in verbindung gebracht werden in bregenz
fälschlich nicht in verbindung gebracht
werden das gewesen ist was uns am
ehesten gestartet hat in der ganzen
geschichte
das heißt es ist immer ein inhaltlicher
punkt der da noch rolle spielt das tier
das tier nun wir kämpfen wie die löwen
und das tun wir seit geraumer zeit
außerdem sind diese diese raubkatzen
tatsächlich der tiere die ich persönlich
sehr sehr mag
vor dem hintergrund beinamen eine afrika
erfahrung dann nenne ich ihnen den löbel
das gefällt mir erheblich besser als der
herr beck gesagt ein kaninchen so sind
nicht die schlange quasi dieses können
sprechen möchte ach was ach was die die
werden sich selber entzaubern also diese
kaninchen die werden die werden immer
kürzere sprünge machen von grün weil
irgendwann kommt der praxistest und
dieser praxis das wird vernichtend
ausfallen
wir stehen am vorabend eines eines
heftigen wirtschaftlichen abschwungs wo
es auf ökonomische kompetenz ankommt und
die grünen haben eine ökonomische
kompetenz von exakt null
das heißt sehr wie die werden sich ganz
ganz gewaltig entzaubern
wenn wir über energieversorgung in
diesem land reden und sehr sich das
programm der grünen
da muss ich ihnen sagen das sind auch
keine grünen denn grüne sind
naturschützer was die machen mit mit
ihrer windtechnologien ähnlichen ist
manifeste natur vernichtung also ich
sehe dass tiefenentspannt das ist ein
momentaner high von solcher haben wir
deshalb wird sich legen egal hat völlig
recht auf in unsere hauptgegner wir
nehmen die absolut ersten gegner mit
solchen stimmergebnis noch ernst nehmen
aber im endeffekt werden sich die
inhalte durchsetzen und dann wird man
sehen die neuen kaiser sind nackt ja
hier kirchner junge freiheit rdr golland
wie bewerten sie denn die absicht ihres
fraktionskollegen markt netz neben dem
bundestagsmandat auch das mandat in der
bremer bürgerschaft wahrzunehmen was
rechtlich nicht verboten ist muss ja
politisch nicht unbedingt sinnvoll sein
und sie selber haben ja als sie in den
bundestag gewählt worden sind 2017 ihr
mandat in potsdam niedergelegt das hat
herr merkt nichts völlig alleine zu
entscheiden
dazu habe ich keine meinung das ist
bremen ist ein
freizeit parlament der landtag in
brandenburg eine andere situation ich
glaubte nicht vereinbaren zu können
ein mandat in einem doch berufs
parlament und einem und der fraktion im
bundestag
daher ist das überhaupt nicht
vergleichbar sagt gerade das dfb nicht
mit dem klima thema in verbindung
gebracht werde ich mein wundert sie das
sie läuten denn den menschengemachten
klimawandel
warum sollte man sie denn da in
irgendeiner weise verbindung bringen
hauser mit verachtung unter machen sie
auch einen leugner des menschgemachten
klimawandels wie ihre kollegen
also wenn sie wer sie sich die mühe
geben die sich offenkundig nicht geben
wir zum beispiel mal genau zu
dann könnten sie feststellen dass sich
immer wieder auch in meinen
wahlkampfreden übrigens gesagt habe dass
wir eine letztlich um gesicherte
datenbasis haben das heißt es geht nicht
um die leugnungen menschengemachten
klimawandel sondern es geht darum dass
wir die daten nicht so gut gesichert
haben wir haben sie werden von mir nicht
hören es gibt keinen menschen gemachten
klimawandel
sie werden von mir auch nicht hören es
gibt einen menschengemachten klimawandel
ich sage wir haben zweifel und ich werde
würde mir wünschen dass die sogenannte
klimapolitik den vorbehalt des zweifels
den vorbehalt des irrtums in stärkerem
maße zunächst als sie das tut was sie
jetzt schon in der fragestellung drin
haben allein dass der begriff der
leugnung geht in genau diesen links
ideologischen touch reihen der unser
land krank macht und das sind sie und
das bin ich
das heißt wir müssen wir müssen wenn wir
eine eine sinnvolle umstellung haben
wollen in der
in der energiepolitik die sogenannte
klimapolitik ist im kern energiepolitik
dann müssen wir erstmal eine saubere
analyse machen wie viel prozent der
jeweiligen energieträger haben wir denn
wir haben ja fossile wie viel haben wir
klare energie die viel haben wir haben
mehr regenerative technologien und dann
müssen wir oder energien
dann müssen wir schauen was ist sinnvoll
wie kann man diesen wie kann man diesen
diesen umstieg vollziehen
und da sind wir nun alles andere als
lang daran arbeite gerade ich seit
einiger zeit intensiv weil mich das
thema persönlich in hohem maße
interessiert und ich muss ihnen wirklich
sagen es widert mich zum teil an wieder
vorgegangen wird wenn gesagt wird wir
würden werden hier diejenigen die
sozusagen für no future stimmen ich
persönlich habe fünf kinder ich habe
zwei enkelkinder ich habe eine sehr sehr
hohe zukunftskonferenz ich sage das
immer wieder
ich werde doch nicht eine politik
propagieren die meinen kindern und
enkeln die lebensgrundlagen ich sag es
mal salopp unterm arsch wegzieht ganz
gewiss nicht sondern ich schaue ich
schaue nach einem vernünftigen
energiemix und das tun wir als partei im
ganzen auf und ich würde mir sehr
wünschen dass wir es ntt olo visieren in
einen vernünftigen fakten basierten
diskurs eintreten dann kämen wir sehr
viel weiter als mit der politik in die
grünen da betreiben